there's a new show coming out produced
by nbc and nfl films a television series
called earning it the nfl's forward
progress which i don't believe is about
the rescinding of the emphasis of the
taunting rule unfortunately
fortunately what it is is making sure
everybody understands about what's
called being called breaking the grass
ceiling
it's a groundbreaking new podcast
featuring the stories of women in the
nfl it's hosted by the nfl's senior
director of diversity and inclusion sam
rappaport
and it is executive produced by
jane skinner goodell a long time
television anchor
for 20 years and now at the forefront of
the national football league as always
back here on the rich eisen show jane
skinner goodell how are you jane
hey rich uh it's not about the taunting
rule but it is produced by a bearish fan
so
uh
do you don't get me in
trouble me my opinion about last night
okay so
do you at least uh turn to who might
ever be next to you on the couch or
in that famous barca lounger that i saw
on a zoom years ago and say what gives
does that ever happen let's just say we
have a family group text i grew up in
chicago as you know we have a family
group text going that um the commish is
on so he hears it he hears it
okay i don't need to say a word
you let the rest of the text exchange
yeah kick it up the chain of command is
just most savage on the text is my 83
year old mom biggest bears fan you'll
ever meet okay
um we can lay it down okay do you want
to let us know what she texted to the
group last night it was all clean it was
all clean okay good very good it's a
family but she loves her bears very much
very good okay so let's talk about this
pod that dropped as the kids say today
uh why and and what would you like
people to know about it
well you know it's actually i'm
producing a podcast and a tv series
which is going to be on peacock we're
familiar with that's coming in january
very good um but the idea is it's it's
really it's a ton of there's ton of
football in both the podcast and the
series but they're really about change
and so as you said i worked in you know
as a tv reporter for 20 years and i
guess i know a good story or i love a
good story and
the concept if i had told you and chris
five or six years ago that there would
be at the super bowl 2021 that there
would be a female official on the field
there would be two female coaches who
are on the tampa bay buccaneers super
bowl winning team you probably would
have looked at me like i had three heads
so the pace of change of bringing women
into the most male dominated sport in
the world
um has been just so rapid and within
five years time they're you know i think
this year where there are six full-time
female coaches i think this summer there
were 12 in
some interns and training camps and
it's remarkable to me so i really what i
really wanted to do is just kind of
chronicle it and talk a lot really
honestly about how how that idea came
about first of all and how that change
actually happens that you know you can't
just wave a magic wand and say
hey let's have some diversity and
inclusion there's you know it's a lot of
challenges um but there are a ton of
people that we talked to with a lot of
head coaches players
who have been very instrumental in the
change and i think people might be
surprised to kind of hear the story
about how it has all happened and how
it's playing out and how it's just
beginning okay who do you have on who'd
you get uh to uh as guests here and part
of the episode one is roger goodell i've
heard of him okay
we had to make it episode two it's kind
of like episode 1b because he sat with
sam right before the host whose idea
this all was by the way she created the
pipeline for women which is why she's
hosting this and she says she's
fantastic she played uh professional
women's tackle football she was a
quarterback so she knows the game uh
better than you rich i might even say
so if she is a better athlete she could
run run rich run uh run sam run i like
that okay
um anyhow so but she he sat with her it
was a 30 minute uh interview window and
she sat with her for two hours uh they
talked a ton about football they talked
a ton about the importance of diverse
voices and and how players and coaches
and teams organizations just want to win
and they don't care what you look like
or what gender you are what ethnicity
race where you were born where you came
from if you can help me win and teach me
um you know ways to do that i'm all in
so we talked to him we talked to kevin
stefanski of the browns ron rivera
washington football team
sean mcdermott at the bills is great you
know his daughter dressed up as a female
coach for halloween
uh and um billie jean king came on which
was incredible because she brazilians
was on too and she and bruce are kind of
have a mutual admiration society
and she was fantastic just about talking
about how you have to be pragmatic if
you want to change something
you know and somebody says no or stands
in your way or doesn't believe in it
move on because you are going to find
someone and in this case there are
men right that have to be involved and
are involved and are very involved um
and find the ones who want to help you
make the change and you can't waste your
time worrying about the ones who don't
um
and then the last episode which i don't
want to give it away but we're going to
do an all-access pass to the making of
the super bowl halftime show it's
executive produced by a woman
and we have a special guest
mystery guest who's going to take us be
like our halftime historian kind of take
us through the history
in audio format at halftime which will
be super fun earn it again is the name
of this podcast and then a a five part
series coming to nbc and uh coming to
peacock in january which is good okay
and i'm impressed because most people
say earning with the g but rich you're
so bright that you got it it's vernon
well it's
apostrophe jane i mean you know i mean
you understand what a lead pipe wielding
professional broadcaster and host sounds
like you know so you would know that i
mean it says earning it right here um
okay and so um what do you want people
to know out of this thing i mean like
literally because we we do hear about
diversity we hear about inclusivity and
um and clearly you know as you call it
it's a male-dominated sport um what do
you want people to get out of this
i think the most important thing is it's
we're not making this is a really big
deal for me to say we're not making
female content for women we are making
content that is for everyone you know
it's obviously for football fans because
we've got head coaches players the
commission coming on a ton of football
but if even if you're not a football fan
it's really a story we're talking about
a story about change in 2021
and how that plays out and and how you
navigate obstacles it's a story about
perseverance resilience uh you know sam
is very big on going there and asking
the questions when you're sarah thomas
she said to her what is the worst thing
that people have said to you on the
field and
they give strategies which i think is
really helpful for like think about your
kids as they're navigating a world with
social media and there's
you know just negativity out there and
they all give strategies for how do you
deal with that and how do you deal with
obstacles in your way and
um you know be resilient um so i think
at the end of the day
it's the lessons that are offered here
are for kind of all generations and also
for other industries if there are you
know other industries out there that are
trying to you know kind of change the
makeup of how they do things and bring
in other points of view it's a pretty
interesting experiment that the nfl has
done and done brilliantly it's not
without its challenges um and they're
still in the process of it it's only
five years in so
i guess that's a lot that i want people
to take from it well i mean i i i
listened to the first episode uh jane on
the way down uh to work today um and can
you tell sam rappaport for me you know
um uh that
should i should i be concerned that she
wants my host chair cause you know i'm
not saying i need to be in charge of
diversity inclusion you know it should
go both ways you know what i mean like
because she did did she did she make the
commissioner cry did she pull some sort
of like you know roy firestone moment on
him did that mean to but he did start to
cry
i think she felt bad
but then you know she's like you and i
she's a real broadcaster and she said oh
i think that's a tease we made the
commissioner cry okay so that actually
happened all right in episode one very
good okay jane uh i really appreciate
the time good luck with this pod and
people can get it all where where where
podcasts are required now and then look
in january for the five part series
right here on peacock correct yeah
peacock so okay very good no you got it
uh anything else i need to know what's
going on what do you what do you got
what are you guys uh uh binge watching
what is the commissioner the national
football league and his wife benoit
binge watch do you have time for that
sort of thing
rewatch and re-watch and re-watch nfl
football games
are you serious that is the rule in our
house there's no other television
allowed there's no game of thrones
there's no there's no
succession the commissioner's not
watching success we have been trying um
a little ted lasso a little succession
just kind of your typical ones but i'm
not kidding you when you know what he's
like it's all football all the time so
as my dad said when roger asked him if
he could marry me i've prepared her well
for this life okay very good
jane skinner goodell thanks very much um
i look forward for everybody else
catching the podcast earning it as i
said correctly um it's called uh earning
it go uh go get it we're all podcasts
required right now thanks for the time
thanks rich
you got it there you go that's there's
jane skinner goodell right there saying
goodbye to you well we we met we had a
great time at the super bowl that's true
that's true minneapolis she she must not
hear your thoughts on deflategate
clearly ever she agree with me
chris i'm going to walk you shut up okay
careful
all right
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here